لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل ينضم الينا من
حيفا الكاتب المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي
ايهاب جبارين سيد جبارين اهلا بك على شاشه
الجزيره هل يتم استعمال او استخدام حادثه
يوم امس في غزه ومقتل هذا العدد الكبير من
الجنود الاسرائيليين والضباط وقودا للحرب
بمعنى انه بدل ان يثبط كابنه الحرب بالعكس
يحاول كابنه الحرب استعماله للاستمرار في
هذه
الحرب نعم تحي استاذ شوان وصباح صح الخير
يعني بطبيعه الحال بدون الن شك هذه
الحادثه سوف تكون ذو حدين للجانب الشع
الاسرائيلي وهي سوف تكون وقود وقود في
داخل غزه ووقود في داخل تل ابيب على حد
سواه الجانب العسكري بدون اذن شك او عفوا
الجانب السياسي بدون اذنى شك سوف يستعملها
الى ذلك البعد نتنياهو وسوتش وبين فير ومن
لف لفي فهم سوف يستعملها لكي ان ياخذ هذه
الحرب الى ابعادها الاكبر والابعد وان
هنالك بالذات بان في ال ال 48 ساعه
الراهنه سوف يكون هنالك حاله من الاحتقان
في داخل الشعر الاسرائيلي ووجوب حاله
الانتقام تماما كما كان في لدينا في
اسبوعين ما بعد السابع من اكتوبر ايه طبعا
هذه الحاله سوف يحاول تكريسها واستغلالها
هذا الجانب السياسي سوف
يحاول وضوع هذا الوقود لكي يكون ببعض
الممارسات التصعيد في داخل القطاع على حد
سواه وربما هذا ما يريد ان يسمعه في هذه
الاثناء الشارع الاسرائيلي بالاجماع في
حاله انيه ولكن ما ان تنتهي هذه الحاله
حاله الحداد 48 ساعه التي ربما نشهد فيها
حاله من
الوحده السطحيه في داخل اسرائيل سوف تشكل
هذه الحادثه وقودا للتصعيد في داخل تلبيب
في داخل كل ما يجري في الاحتجاجات
الميدانيه في داخل تلبيب لان في نهايه
المطاف هذه الحرب ليس فقط انها لم تطيح
بحماس هذه العدوان لفس فقط بانه لم يعيد
الاسر بل اكثر من ذلك هو يعيد الجنود
بالتوابيت وبالجمله هذه الامور لا يستطيع
ان يستوعبها الشاعر الاسرائيلي ولا يستطيع
ان يتقبلها وبالذي نعم هنالك حالتي تصعيد
واحده سوف تكون في غزه والثانيه قطعا سوف
تكون في تلبي دعنا ننوه الى هذا الخبر
العاجل بحسب مراسل الجزيره الجيش
الاسرائيلي يواصل حصار مستشفى الخير
وجامعه الاقصى التي تؤوي نازحين غرب خان
يونس اعود اليك سيد جبارين هل يخشى هل بات
نتنياهو اكثر خشيه من ان يحاسب على فشلين
فشل 7 اكتوبر وفشل العمليه البريه في
غزه يعني لاحظ ان حتى هذه اللحظه العمليه
البريه لم تكتب في البروتوكول كعمليه بريه
لانه لم يكن هنالك اجماع في داخل الكابينت
حول هذه العمليه ولماذا هذا لانه لم يكن
يريدون شركاء بنيامين نتنياهو جانس
ايزنكوت وغيرهم وحتى المستوى الامني ان
ياخذ الاستخبارات وتحديدا ان ياخذ تبعيات
هذا الامر اراد ان يسجل اذا كان هنالك صور
نجاح طبعا بدون ان نشك النجاح لديه اباء
كثر واذا كانت هنالك صوره فشل هي لن تبقى
يتيمه بهذه الحاله بالمناسبه بل هي سوف
تسجل فوق جبين بنيامين نتنياهو فنعم
فبالتالي واضح جدا ان بنيامين نتنياهو هو
يعلم ان كل ما يحدث معه ما بعد السابع من
اكتوبر هو يسمى
يعني بالاضرار الجانبيه فبالتالي الضربه
القاسيه الضربه القاضيه هو تلقاها في
السابع من اكتوبر بعد السابع من اكتوبر كل
ما يحدث له من فشل هو اضرار جانبيه ضربات
جانبيه يعني ولهذا السبب يذهب في المقامره
والمغامره على كل الاوراق التي بيده لهذا
السبب هو لا يابه كثيرا بتبعي هذا الامر
لانه يعلم احد ووحيد هو وصل الى نقطه اللا
غفران القضاء الاسرائيلي لن يغفر له
الشارع الاسرائيلي لن يغفر له وكذلك
السياس الاسرائيليون لن يغفر له ولا
الليكود لن يغفر له كل هؤلاء الاربعه لن
يغفر لبين يمين نتنياهو ما وصل الى ما وصل
اليه وما ال التت به الويل في نهايه
الطريق ولكن هو يستغل نقطه القوه الموجود
فيها في هذه الاثناء كرسي السلطه وكرسي
الحكم وهو يعلم انه في اللحظه التي سوف
ينزل من على هذه الكرسي ويصبح في حاله ضعف
الكل سوف ينتقص منه هؤلاء الاربعه لن
يغفروا له لانه بات هو قد قطع هذه النقطه
بكل تاكيد من حيفا الكاتب المختص الش
الاسرائيلي ايهاب جبارين شكرا جزيلا لك